hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters
ah no punch okay papa that's taken care
of I didn't want to waste the bullets
but I'm hoping they're gonna give me
more oh so tiny bright lights oh that's
all oh that's some sort of illusion
they're trying to get to the big make
the sort of a cash end oh ha ha
interesting interesting
whoa that is not a normal fan this does
not seem safe at all
whoa shotgun ha ha
how do you open that door oh no I'm not
gonna waste the ammo on come here yeah
what's up all your shaggy head Oh
finally I'm getting in some brighter
areas
battle Reid now I have pills yes oh oh
yes okay
oh okay making progress oh it's one of
those things what are these things
anyway are these zombie monsters come
here come here come here
ah yeah okay those doctor once seemed to
be a little weaker than this shotgun oh
yeah
oh yeah all right anyway ah come here
come here I'm gonna try it see how
powerful this thing if it doesn't one
shot it all right there we go that's
more like it
that is more like it yes please
well hello come here oh yeah
all right there's a Spiti guy kind of
want to take him out but if I don't have
to that'd be fine too
if I can get around him all right what's
up guy what's up friend
what's this please fruit off [ __ ]
[ __ ] hell okay
if I can just
[Applause]
am I going even
it's gun on the table over there but I'm
pretty sure I already have a gun I'll
just take care of
it's modeled off of that spinner guy
[ __ ] that wasted way too much em I need
to get closer come on die oh my god
Jamie missed I'm such a tool [ __ ] this
I'm going back to that get on top of him
strategy ride him like a crocodile my
[ __ ] house no no get on top of him
get on top of it okay
yeah that's cool too or I can fail
that's always an option fine you know
what you're gonna have face full of shot
you're gonna have face full of pistol
let's screw you buddy
miss
oh now you move UK me suddenly you
decide oh you can't get through all [ __ ]
you can what your rapid fire now what
the [ __ ] there oh my god [ __ ] that
[ __ ] what is this a different type of
gun it's got more bullets as a Glock
Glock as opposed to a whatever someone
said in the comments what it was I don't
expect don't care
I do not care right now I'm very very
irritated your I could have just jumped
up here at any time I don't care about
anything or anyone in any way no I care
about nothing all the care has gone for
my soul now you even need to come this
way why am I even here where's the way
out where's the way out what was the
point of all that seriously what was the
point of all that
like what in the hell must be something
to do with getting up here right I mean
right I suck I don't even know I I'm
really kind of just confused right now
strain the block here I don't know I
don't know oh oh this is not a good
episode for me no okay seriously what
the hell am i doing am I supposed to get
up there somehow I don't know I really I
really had a loss nope dad failed what
about some reason for coming here and
killing that guy right other than the
fact that he was just defending a gun
maybe there's no reason to be in here
maybe I maybe this whole thing was just
a waste of time
okay all right I guess I can't get back
so what the hell am I supposed to do I
[Music]
am an [ __ ]
I don't care guys just pushing my
buttons everything wants get on my bad
side
everything everything must die
everything must die huh
haha what glock is more powerful that
was the hand mouths guy
oh those that's the monster that they
put in cry of fear as well ah okay okay
so they got it from here that was in the
the secret PewDiePie level all right wow
that's phenomenal
I'm so happy that this all I got up here
now love this let's get [ __ ] god damn
in your heart ah where'd you come from
ah ha ha perfect opportunity save some
ammo did horse rider zombie
[Music]
yep I sure wish I had a crowbar
uphills oh thank you everything I'm
creeping up back on full health like I
don't think I'll get there okay damn it
I see you
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
[ __ ] you don't don't worry I'll take
that mom I'm not gonna autosave out of
every single bit of damage it's just
when things I know that things get hairy
and I need all the help I can get
sometimes
all right I just got to be careful Oh
what was that
God Oh back here
okay back to once again this is not a
normal fan this is not sir I stood up I
let my I'll okay okay gang I am okay
really I went all that way just to get
down here
what no way what the hell was that
did that hurt really
that hurt
so mad I'm so mad
I'm
[Music]
that's all the time I got for this
episode thank you all for watching
see you in the next board